people take a oh sweet class especially  my version most of the students may sink  uncertainty principle is actually  related to completely related to quantum  mechanics so actually it is actually  another case actually uncertainty  principle almost have nothing to do with  quantum mechanics it has to do with just  a wave description we employ when we  describe the system so that's actually  one of the pics in which we learn from  our three the other thing which people  will learn a lot more essentially that  before they come to look us they may  think is almost impossible to understand  infinite number of coupled oscillators  and it turns out that there is a very  systematic way you can actually make use  of simple symmetry argument and that you  can actually create a simplified  complicated system like infinitely long  system so so it is actually another  impossible task and everything can be  actually understand using the concept of  symmetry which we introduced in iostream